[MUSIC]
The US system is designed to do nothing.
So that means to get something passed and
to become a law you need a majority in the
house.
You need a super majority in the senate,
and
you also need the President to sign it.
Right?
And that's aside from
other institutional constraints, like the
committee system, and so on, right?
So when the Democrats hold the majority,
and the Democrats hold the White House,
the US system is gonna restrain their
agenda, right?
That's just the way the system is, that's
the way the founders intended.
[MUSIC]
What we do in this study, is to try to ask
the question, why?
Why has the institution evolved to look
the way it does?
And so what we do is we examine two much
maligned aspects of the U.S.
political institution,
they are supermajority role and the
delegation of authority to bureaucrats.
Now both of these can be seen as
undemocratic.
The filibuster rule and that it's not
respecting majority rule,
it's not representing the people as well
as it should.
And the delegation to bureaucrats who are
unelected, all right?
So it's often asked why is authority
delegated to these sorts of
people who aren't elected by the people?
[MUSIC]
What we find is that,
these two components, the super majority
filibuster rule and the delegation of
authority to unelected bureaucrats, on
their own have seemed very undemocratic.
Put together, all right?
They work in such a way that the
interdependence actually leads to
better policy outcomes than we otherwise
would achieve.
[MUSIC]
What most analysis or most commentary on
the gridlock misses is
that there's a lot of action happening in
the background.
And what we're trying to point out is a
lot of this action
is happening via delegation.
So Congress may fight.
They may be able to, may not be able to
agree about whether the tax rate should be
a little higher or a little lower.
But what they can agree upon, in a world
that's changing over time,
is that they want policy to be smoothed
out in a sense,
to not change too much as the world
changes, to react to the changing world.
All right?
Because one thing that politicians like,
particularly incumbent politicians is,
they like the status quo.
All right?
They like the world to not change because
that world is what got them elected.
And so, as much as they can, they'd like
to keep the world the way it is.
Gridlock serves that purpose.
And so, to that extent, it's kind of
locking down the world or
locking down some policies for the
interests of these policymakers.
That allows deals to be made in Congress.
And what we're trying to show in this
research is that delegation is
a way that Congress can overcome the
problems of gridlock and get deals done.
[MUSIC]
So to take a recent example, we can look
at the Dodd-Frank Bill where a lots of
authority was reg, delegated to the
financial regulators.
Now, that may have been a puzzle.
Why didn't Congress think there's nothing
more [UNKNOWN] or
nothing more important in the last five
years than financial reform?
Why didn't Congress figure out the answer
themselves?
What they did was, they delegated
authority to the regulators,
because they didn't know how the world was
going to change.
What Congress people could agree upon is
that they wanted to find a solution.
And I didn't know what it was, and I
didn't know what it would be tomorrow, but
the deal they struck was to delegate that
authority to a regulator,
who had different preferences to them.
So it may seem undemocratic, but
it's those different preferences that
allow the deal to happen.
Yesterday, Democrats and Republicans
agreed something needed to be done.
I didn't know what it was, but
they could agree to delegate authority to
that agency.
Tomorrow, when the agency starts figuring
out what the answer is, Republicans or
maybe Democrats don't like it, but
they can't back track, they can't roll it
back, precisely because of gridlock.
[MUSIC]
Gridlock has its pluses and has its
minuses.
All right?
It does stop things from happening and it
frustrates a lot of people.
What we're trying to show here is the
gridlock may not be as bad as it,
bad as it seems.
And that other aspects of the political
institution go a long way to
solving the problems or solving the
inefficiencies of gridlock.
[MUSIC]